Star Trek obviously you this this role
you you so nailed the role of Captain
Kirk he did such a brilliant job I would
think it would be intimidating to enter
this the realm of Star Trek because
Trekkies are very particular this is
their religion yeah were you anxious
were they with about how they would
receive the new Captain Kirk well yeah
you know you always want to do a good
job and you want to be yeah especially
with something that that's this beloved
you want to do do the part justice and
you know we've as we've kind of promoted
the film and gone around we've
encountered people and it always it
always seems like people are very you
know they're very sad to see Spock and
Zachary Quinto Spock very excited to see
seven pegs to Scotty and then the the
what I love is usually what I find with
people that that encounter me they're
like well when we first heard that you
were gonna do we were so scared we're so
worried we you knew that we knew you
weren't gonna nail it terrible you were
so fine always the ellipses and then the
Advocate early searching quick
wonderfully mediocre no no no I mean
you're aware you did you destroy it was
fantastic you did amazing
very hard choose to fill the way
everybody interprets that role that was
amazing tell us about people like us
this is the film you're promoting yeah
people like us Alex Kurtzman who was one
of the writers on Star Trek wrote and
directed this film that's kind of based
on his life it's heavily fictionalized
but essentially I play a character that
is having the worst day of his life he
finds out that he's a major debt and his
father passes away he has to go home and
see his mom who he hasn't seen in a long
time
and and then he gets $150,000 in cash
which he's obviously very excited about
but it turns out the money is for this
woman he he's never met this the sister
that he never knew about that his father
had with another woman that means you
had no idea you had a sister I had no
idea and I think the clip that you have
I'm encountering her basically for the
first time and I'm I haven't told her
who I am so she has no idea but I'm very
aware of the actor playing your sister
is Elizabeth what's that take a look at
this clip from people like us
can I get you something
that they sell here
no no no no look look I I swear to you
on my life I am NOT and will never hit
on me ever Wow
thank you I'm sure that was meant to
reassure me I'm sure you get hit on all
the time but not one of those guys I'm
gonna relay tschappat oh so great for
you what's his name
[Applause]